Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Je vais vous parler de Helvécia,
ce village brésilien au nom suisse.
Cette histoire a commencé pour moi
quand j’ai fait un road trip au Brésil,
dans l'État de Bahia.
Je suis tombé sur une plaque au bord de
la route où il était inscrit « Helvécia »,
avec une orthographe un peu différente
de celle qu’on connaît.
J’ai demandé à Milena Machado Neves,
une journaliste brésilienne,
native de la région,
ce qu’elle savait de ce lieu.
Elle m’explique que c’est un « quilombo ».
Un quilombo est un ancien refuge
fondé par des personnes réduites
en esclavage, en fuite,
comme il en existe
dans tous les pays post-coloniaux.
Par exemple, dans les colonies
britanniques, ce sont les Marroons,
ou encore en Colombie, c’est les Palancas.
Je réponds :
« Mais Helvécia, c’est la Suisse,
c’est la personnification de la Suisse. »
Moi qui ai grandi en Suisse,
je n’ai jamais entendu parler
de lien entre la Suisse,
l’esclavage et le Brésil.
Mais bon, on continue notre route
et cette histoire m'intrigue.
Je commence à faire des recherches et
tombe sur différents travaux d’historiens
qui expliquent que Helvécia,
c’était la colonie Leopoldina,
fondée en 1818 par une poignée
de Suisses et d’Allemands
qui avaient recours à l’esclavage
pour produire du café.
Et là, je propose à Milena qu’on y aille,
qu’on aille voir à quoi ça ressemble.
Et fin 2015, on y va.
En arrivant, on ne trouve rien
qui rappelle la Suisse,
à part le nom du village sur un
des bâtiments de la place du village.
On commence à demander
aux gens qu’on croise
ce qu’ils connaissent du lien
entre leur Helvécia et la Suisse.
Mais personne ne sait trop
ce que Helvécia veut dire.
On va croiser des jeunes
qui vont nous montrer les alentours.
Là, c’est le fleuve Peruipe qui est le
fleuve d’où partait le café de la colonie.
Aujourd’hui presque asséché.
On veut en savoir un peu plus,
alors, on va aux archives publiques
de l’État de Bahia à Salvador.
Là, c’est l’entrée du bâtiment.
On va trouver plusieurs documents
intéressants sur la colonie,
dont ce tableau de 1848 où on peut
voir le nom des plantations,
le nom de leur propriétaire, une colonne
« Blancs » et une autre « Esclaves »,
qui indiquent le nombre de blancs
et de personnes réduites en esclavage
sur chaque plantation.
On peut y voir que
c’est un ratio de 1 à 10.
Il y avait 130 blancs pour 1267
personnes réduites en esclavage.
À l’apogée de la colonie,
une dizaine d’années après,
ça va monter à 200 blancs
pour 2000 personnes réduites en esclavage.
On y trouve aussi une plantation
qui s’appelle Helvécia,
de Johann Martin Flach,
un des fondateurs suisses de la colonie.
C’est cette plantation qui, plus tard,
va donner le nom au village.
Aux alentours d’Helvécia, on trouve
cette tombe de Joao Flach,
le fils de Johann Martin Flach,
qui est né et a grandi dans la colonie.
Son père l’a envoyé en Suisse
faire des études d’agronomie.
À son retour, il a repris
les plantations de son père,
puis il est mort noyé
dans le fleuve Peruipe en 1868.
Après cet événement, sa femme
et ses enfants sont revenus en Suisse
avec l’équivalent actuel
de trois millions de francs suisses.
En Suisse, on va faire
la rencontre de Christian Doninelli,
un journaliste fribourgeois qui travaille
aussi sur l’histoire d’Helvécia.
On décide d’allier nos forces
et de commencer à faire des recherches
dans les archives publiques suisses.
On va par exemple trouver ce document
aux archives d’État de Neuchâtel,
un bilan comptable de 1827,
de l’entreprise Pombal,
de trois associés neuchâtelois -
Béguin, Huguenin et Borrel -
qui tous avaient
une plantation dans la colonie.
Dans leurs actifs, on trouve le prix
de personnes réduites en esclavage,
dont une enfant.
Sur cette peinture, on peut voir l’ampleur
de la plantation de l’associé Borrel.
Une peinture que j’ai trouvée
dans une collection privée de Genève.
Et en 1860,
à l’apogée de la colonie,
la Confédération décide
d’implanter un vice-consulat
dans la ville portuaire voisine,
Caravelas,
d’où est exporté le café
directement vers l’Europe.
En 1888, l’abolition de l’esclavage
est enfin promulguée au Brésil.
On a aussi trouvé ce document
aux archives fédérales de Berne,
une lettre qui date
de trois mois après l’abolition,
écrite de la main du vice-consul suisse
Frédéric-Louis Jeanmonod,
qui a aussi une plantation
dans la colonie.
C’est vraiment un appel
à l’aide à la Suisse.
Il y explique que tout va mal
par chez eux,
que s’ils n’ont pas d’indemnité pour
les ex-esclaves, ils sont tous ruinés.
À cette même période,
de grosses révoltes commencent à Helvécia,
la majorité des colons vont fuir
et les ex-esclaves vont
rester sur les terres.
En 1895,
c’est la fermeture du vice-consulat
parce qu’il n’y a presque
plus de Suisses dans la région.
Nous, on va retourner beaucoup à Helvécia
et on va commencer à s’intéresser
aux descendants de cette histoire,
à leur héritage culturel
et à la vie quotidienne du village.
Elle, c’est dona Cocota.
En 2015, quand j’ai fait
cette photo, elle avait 105 ans.
Elle est toujours parmi nous maintenant.
C’est un lien direct
avec ce passé douloureux -
car elle a été élevée par son grand-père
qui a été une partie de sa vie
réduit en esclavage
et qui lui a raconté beaucoup
d’histoires de cette époque -
mais aussi vers le futur.
Parce qu’elle a été sage-femme
durant toute sa vie.
Elle nous dit avoir fait naître
308 enfants du village.
Un jour, on tombe sur cette scène :
une file d’enfants
peu avant Noël dans le village.
Ils attendaient des cadeaux
d’une association évangélique
qui donnait des camions aux petits garçons
et des poupées blanches
aux petites filles.
Une fois qu’ils avaient reçu
leurs cadeaux, les enfants sortaient
et les bénévoles de l’association
commençaient à taper des mains
en scandant :
« Jésus t’aime, Jésus t’aime. »
Voilà un jeune séminariste
en retard à la messe.
Elvis Elisiario de Jesus,
qui va devenir le premier père
afro-descendant de l’ancienne colonie.
Il y a une légende urbaine
qui se raconte beaucoup là-bas,
comme quoi les ex-esclaves n’avaient pas
été tenus au courant de l’abolition
et ça ne serait qu’une année après
qu’un père de passage
leur aurait appris la nouvelle.
On est tombé sur cet habitant
qui n'avait plus de toit.
Il nous explique que,
peu de temps auparavant,
un étranger de passage lui a proposé
d’échanger ses tuiles d’époque
contre le triple de tuiles neuves.
Ce qu’il a accepté.
Ces tuiles d’époque avaient été faites
par des personnes esclavagisées.
Elles avaient un design suisse,
comme on peut encore en trouver
sur d’autres toits du village.
Et lui, c’est Danilon Luiz Francisco,
qui se cache derrière
une croix de fer du 19ᵉ siècle
trouvée dans l’ancien cimetière.
Danilon fait partie de l’association
communautaire qui a aidé à œuvrer
pour que Helvécia soit reconnue
en tant que quilombo officiellement.
Parce qu’au Brésil, les quilombos
ont une reconnaissance de l’État
qui peut par exemple aider la population
à avoir la propriété de leur terre,
suivant depuis combien générations
ils vivent dessus,
ou encore avoir des bourses
pour les jeunes,
pour qu’ils puissent
accéder aux universités.
Mais ce n’était pas chose aisée
d’avoir ce statut
car normalement un quilombo,
c’est un refuge fondé par
des personnes réduites en esclavage.
Et là, ce sont les colons qui avaient fui
et les esclaves qui étaient
restés sur les terres.
Mais ils ont enfin réussi
à avoir ce statut en 2005.
Voici les frères Krull,
Domingos et Ednilson Krull.
Ils sont descendants de la famille
allemande la plus riche de la colonie
qui, à elle seule, avait plus de 120
personnes réduites en esclavage.
Un samedi matin, je suis tombé
sur cette file d’habitants
qui attendaient
pour peut-être être embauchés
par une entreprise leader mondial
de la production de cellulose,
pour travailler
sur leur monoculture d’eucalyptus
qui est très présent dans la région.
La majorité des gens d’Helvécia
y travaillent.
Voici la fête de Saint-Sébastien.
C’est l’événement
le plus important du village.
Ils rejouent une bataille
entre les Maures et les Croisés.
Cet événement attire plus
de 20 000 personnes de la région
et est célébré sur trois jours.
La danse Bate-Barriga.
C’est une danse ancestrale
de cette époque de l’esclavage
qui a été racontée de mère en fille.
Là, c’est Faustina Carvalho sur la
droite qui l’a remise au goût du jour.
Ça veut littéralement dire
« battement de ventre ».
Les femmes se battent
le ventre en dansant.
C’est un des ancêtres de la samba.
Le maître de capoeira du village,
Reginaldo,
qui fait perdurer les traditions
de ses ancêtres avec ses élèves.
Presque tous les jeunes de Helvécia, à
un moment donné, ont fait de la capoeira.
Cet art martial entre danse et lutte
a été interdit au Brésil jusqu’en 1940.
Un soir sur la place du village.
La moto est très populaire à Helvécia.
La majorité des routes et des rues
sont faites en terre battue.
Le cheval aussi est très populaire.
Cette photo a été faite au même
endroit quelques années après.
Voici Iracema Sulz Metzker.
Elle est descendante suisse du côté Sulz,
et allemande du côté Metzker.
Elle nous explique que ses ascendances
européennes sont sa plus grande richesse,
que ça vaut tout l’or du monde,
et que même,
un jour, ils devaient recevoir
un héritage provenant de Suisse,
mais qu’ils ne l’ont pas eu parce que
les Sulz s’appelait Schulz à la base,
mais en arrivant au Brésil, ils ont
perdu quelques lettres à leur nom.
Voici Henrique Cerqueira,
un autre descendant de la famille Sulz,
qui pose avec toute sa famille
devant sa maison.
Quand je faisais ces photos, j’ai vu
du coin de l’œil un cheval arriver.
J’ai attendu qu’il passe
pour déclencher à nouveau.
Le cheval représente pour les religions
afro-descendantes comme le umbanda
le messager entre le corps et les esprits.
Voici le Terreiro Umbanda de Mãe Maria
qui est le lieu de culte
d’un syncrétisme typiquement brésilien
qui est un mélange
entre religion africaine,
christianisme et rites amérindiens.
Un autre soir sur la place du village -
Attila et ses amis.
À Helvécia, pour une population
d’environ 2000 personnes,
il y a 22 églises évangéliques.
Toutes les deux semaines,
une messe évangélique est donnée
sur la place du village.
Et ce soir-là, on a été très frappé
d’entendre dans leurs sermons
une diabolisation des cultures
et des religions afro-descendantes,
comme le Umbanda de Mãe Maria,
qui, elle, nous dit : « Même si
les évangéliques parlent mal de nous,
de temps en temps, ils viennent
en cachette pour subir un travail
et nous, on les accueille
les bras ouverts. »
Voici une jeune adepte de umbanda
qui vient de subir un travail.
Elle est couverte d’huile de dendé,
qui est de l’huile de palme,
qui est un aliment très commun
dans la culture culinaire de la région.
Là, au cimetière du village,
une tombe d’une mère
de son umbanda, comme Mãe Maria.
On m’a raconté qu’après sa mort,
elle apparaissait sans cesse
dans les rêves de ses proches
en leur implorant
de mieux l’enterrer parce qu’elle ne
pouvait pas reposer en paix comme ça.
Donc, au bout d’un moment,
sa famille l’a déterrée, mieux enterrée,
et a rajouté cette cage,
et les apparitions ont cessé.
Voici mon ombre projetée par les phares
d’une voiture sur une famille de Helvécia.
Moi, en tant que Suisse et Brésilien,
je me suis énormément projeté
dans cette histoire,
étant descendant tant d’exploités
que d’exploitants.
Voici une dernière image devant
la bibliothèque de l’école d’Helvécia.
Après plus de cinq ans
de recherche et de travail,
cette enquête, on en a fait un livre.
On l’a fait pour notre devoir
de mémoire et pour nous tous.
Parce que cette histoire fait partie
de l’héritage de nos sociétés actuelles.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)